l'album grand format que les éditions de
la martinière consacre pas joséphine
baker et à la revue offre
davantage qu'un simple recueil
d'illustrations
son propos est double raconter la
fabuleuse révélation que fut la revue
menée par joséphine baker au
théâtre des champs elysées en 1925 et
offrir la reproduction de l'album de
lithographie que le grand affichiste
paul colin publia deux ans plus tard
sous le titre tumulte noir natif de
saint louis missouri
elle a 19 ans quand elle stupéfie la
capitale un corps magnifique une liberté
de mouvement inédite où l'humour le
dispute à la provocation un sens du
rythme
paris déjà fou de l'art africain du rag
éduquer croque s'enflamme pour l'univers
noir le jazz et le charleston que
joséphine symbolise à la perfection une
véritable folie des années folles une
baker magna pour la première fois de ma
vie écrira tél je me suis sentie ben
quant à paul colin son affiche pour la
revue noire rouge et blanche avait saisi
les foules en hommage à paris ville si
accueillante et aux artistes qui font sa
renommée
ils composent cet album de 45
lithographies sous son trait épuré
défilent les artistes de la revue
le chanteur les danseurs et joséphine
baker elle-même bien sûr mais aussi leur
collègue maurice chevalier mistinguett
damian cécile sorel max déry une
fabuleuse parade